le sport en extérieur interdit à paris
donc le sport en extérieur c'est un truc
qui vient de tomber
c'est les dernières infos sera interdite
à paris entre 10h et 19h dès demain
c'est l'amérique qui vient de décider de
cette mesure donc terminée parce que
c'est vrai qu'on avait vu plein de mecs
qui s'était mis au jogging à l'est mais
qu'ils aillent là l'effet jogging de
leur vie vert depuis call coronavirus
tous les mecs cours inde et que tu vois
un mec il court maintenant il n'a jamais
couru de sa venir un jour il a couru
après le bus mais c'est tout et là
maintenant les mecs les vols courir
courir courir courir donc là ils ont dit
stop
alors j'ai eu plein de gens qui m'ont
appelé est-ce qu'on peut quand même
marché
est-ce qu'on peut quand même courir mais
sans frère de jogging est-ce qu'on peut
courir avant 10 heures parce que c'est
de 10h à 19h est ce qu'on peut courir
parce qu'en fait je pense qu'ils ont
fait ça aussi
de 10 heures à 19 heures parce qu'ils
sont dit le mec qui va courir à 8 heures
c'est un vrai joker c'est pas un mouton
le mec qui se lève à 8 heures pour aller
courir c'est que franchement le mec il
est motivé c'est pas un mec qui s'est
dit il ya deux semaines je vais tâcher
de mettre à courir
jimmy mohammed alors savez de quoi
exactement oui n'en ressens plaignait
hier on comprenait pas pourquoi tout
d'un coup on avait plein de marathonien
des futurs champions olympiques
désormais cette mesure il appelle tout
simplement à paris c'est une bonne
mesure
certains diront que tous les joggeurs
vont se retrouver après 19 heures ou
après 10h15 et crée un effet de foule je
pense qu'au contraire ça va limiter la
fenêtre d'exposition faire en sorte que
les vrais joggeurs éventuellement puisse
courir ce qu'ils sont vraiment
déterminés
donc ça reste une bonne les gens mais
qui voudra peut être appliquée à
l'ensemble du territoire parce que pour
l'instant ces initiatives et ça
n'arrêtait de la mairie taille ni sophie
il l'avait fait rien je crois ni saint
louis et mathieu non ce qui est aberrant
évidemment j'ai regardé ce matin vous
avez toujours le droit de sortir sur un
périmètre de 20 km entre 10h et 19h mais
vous avez le droit si vous marchez et si
vous ne courez pas mais là on marche sur
les mains le dirigé par des charlots
pardon ça veut dire que tu marches même
la barre ce rapide sa part du court ça
passe pas un flic arrive tu dis
finalement je marchais secours est pas
enfin qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
à bientôt ramel calculer à combien de
kilomètres heure en marche la marche
rapide mais jusqu'à 3 km à 3 milliards
bb faut arrêter de sketches c'est
ridicule
ce temps que le confinement faut quand
même être c'est au km 53 minutes 10 me
le confinement s'éloigner de quelques
années pas de près de quelqu'un quand on
court entre 10h et 19h éventuellement
avec un masque qu on est loin des autres
et concours dans un parc
pardon là on fait rien
non ce sont des jours c'est pas ça si ce
n'est se vider la tête et dernière jimmy
effectivement pas d'accord avec mon bac
le fan je fais de pervers se réunir non
le raymond film d'un jeune âge que
manière jimmy nom jésus ce qu'on va dire
du mit le confinement c'est le
confinement si on sort pas du tout et ça
c'est le confinement c'est d'avoir moins
de cinq interactions sociales visuelle
avec des gens lorsque vous courez
lorsqu'on fait un jogging multiplier ces
interactions
si tout le monde fait ça vous donner
aussi un mauvais signal aux gens
pourquoi lui court pourquoi je sortirai
pas me balader
je pense que c'est une dynamique alors
effectivement on peut rentrer dans les
détails oui on aura de marché mais on
n'a pas droit de courir ça peut paraître
action mais l'idée l'ambiance et ne
sortez pas de chez vous d'autant plus
que l'on a vu ce week-end des images
catastrophiques et qu'il va commencer à
fermer et dans certains services du
genre d'urgence
ils sont en train de constater une
augmentation du nombre de cas comme ça
la folle ou jimmy après 19 heures parce
qu'après 10 ans on va tous aller courir
il y aura encore plus de monde coller
dans les rues de paris dans ces cas là
pour enlever complètement jimmy quand on
prend une décision l'apprenant vexille
safran paraît pour prendre une mesure ça
mais les deux mineurs six voitures de la
merde
rené malleville oui moi je passais kg
ils ont pris là cette décision à paris
mais moi je vous a complètement absurde
de donner des heures parce que quand
j'ai vu l'autre jour le lundi le monde
savait dans paris on se serait cru un
jour normal et il n'y a pas qu'à paris
moi je reconnais je suis marseillais
mais quel j'ai vu les images de
marseille pas beau à elie sous la
corniche et où j'étais un peu dégoûté
aussi le code final c'est le confinement
si on commence à dire oui et là parce
que regarder le ce qui s'est passé par
rapport aux déconfinement reste dix ont
dit à tout le monde
restez chez vous et même au niveau de
l'état je parlais pas de tonnes la
blague syrie et même au niveau de l'état
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire le jour
d'après les mains et saigner décision
commente après jude après c'est quand ça
va arriver
alors qu on est plus à deux reprises le
sort alors ne parlera arrêtés qu'ils
arrêtent de parler du décompte cinéma le
jour d'après les choses avancent et est
peut-être déjà respecte europe des clubs
plus alors si vous pouvez sortir du
déconfinement juste un rappel pour aller
vraiment aider des personnes âgées pour
leur donner peut-être des courses etc
ça c'est important pour aller à votre
travail si vous pouvez pas bien sûr
faire autrement à faire du télétravail
pour aller regarder vos enfants vous
voir vos enfants voilà pas pour aller
pour les gars des perdants ils servent à
regarder voilà la garde alternée ou
détruits comme ça voilà il ya plusieurs
cas mais le jogging voilà après c'est
pas indispensable on mesure là on peut
se passer de jogging pendant un mois oui
et rivés au ciel il croit être équitable
où la plupart des troupes provenant pas
des joggeurs il y a qu'à se promener par
exemple on voit des gens on voit bien
que voilà ce sont des contrevenants qui
vont faire un tour et on ne sanctionne
que les joggeurs mois à courir sa
manière de décompresser c'est l'avenir
de vêtements causé beaucoup de gens
pourquoi c'est cette catégorie là qui
est qui est frappée pourquoi avait il un
type à qu'il faut pas sortir du tout
bravo alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs car les téléspectateurs
qu'ils en pensent quoi s'il vous plaît
on a un sondage là dessus le jogging
interdit à paris entre 10h à 19h pour à
82% contre 1 18% et d'envoyer moi
j'étais pas pour mais maintenant je suis
pour
voilà merci les chéris